[Music]
i hesitate to get rid of a lot of things
for our son but we also don't have a lot
of storage how do minimalist families
handle this congratulations you don't
have a lot of storage which means you're
not paying for a bunch of excess space
that you don't need now ryan imagine if
at your apartment you
had that same square footage in a house
but now you had a basement and attic and
it was costing you twice as much to be
in that space
you'd effectively be paying
for
storage space yeah now it's not to say
that storage is bad or evil here at our
studio downstairs we have a storage
annex with a few things in there that we
apply our 90 90 rule to have i used this
in the last 90 days if not will i use it
in the next 90 days if not we try to
sell it or donate it or recycle it or
eventually maybe even trash it
so jacqueline congratulations
saying i don't have a whole lot of
storage
let's reframe that i don't have to pay
for a bunch of excess space that i am
not using
and so when you say i hesitate to get
rid of things from my son
well why do you hesitate to get rid of
them if he's no longer using them then
you're assigning a meaning to them that
he's probably not assigning to them at
all we don't
as kids we don't start assigning meaning
to physical things until around age four
age five and the only reason we tend to
do that is because we see our parents do
it right yeah
man i would just pause with jacqueline
that your son probably doesn't need 95
of the stuff that you think he needs
i mean
i in fact if you look at the opposite
there's probably a thousand or two
thousand more items that uh you could
probably talk yourself into getting for
your son talking yourself into the fact
that he needs them i mean what do kids
really need they need a good home they
need some clothes they need food they
need shelter they need water they need
some toys they need some entertainment
they need love
but i think often we we make the mistake
of
falling for a lot of uh
it's not just marketing that's a piece
of it but we also see you know our
friends and what they have for their
children oh my child would be happier if
they had x y or z and uh that's a lot of
the times not the case
and quite often i end up regretting the
things that we buy for ella
and here's why because it distracts her
from
living
the life that keeps her in the moment
yeah the tablet is a great example of
this right
i
if there's one the worst thing i've ever
done as a parent is provide a glowing
screen to even though like we don't let
her watch it all the time
and i don't want to deprive her of it at
the same time i can see what it does to
her yeah so quite often the things that
we get for our kids simply get in the
way of them living their life
now ella got a few physical gifts for
christmas not from me or bex because we
only bought her experiences this past
christmas
but some of her extended family of
course feels compelled to give
tchotchkes and nonsense and
and uh fine uh if they want to do that
it's not totally fine because it's not
really respecting our wishes but we
but
then ella opens them on christmas
morning
guess what the thing she played with
most was
the packing peanuts from one of the
packages
in which this was sent in
so i mean the christmas morning yeah she
was pretending
one of the things that was sent had all
of these
horrible styrofoam packing i mean it was
this whole case of step packing penis
and she was pretending it was snowing
throwing them up in the air rolling
around in the making snow angels and the
and she enjoyed
the trash
more than the other things which she
basically treated like trash after
opening them note to self just give ella
a box of packing peanuts have we ever
told the story of the
what we did to celebrate your promotion
back in the corporate world yes we have
okay we can rehash it out
and when you say we it wasn't me well we
as in the people who worked for you so
twice i've had someone come out to me
and randomly ask for my car keys
and both times i regretted it once was
uh
uh a family member who stole something
out of my car
uh this was like way back uh probably 15
20 years ago 15 years ago uh and then
the other time was when i got a
promotion
um
i'm i'm like at my retail store
i'm like finishing up the last things i
need to finish up at the retail store
and josh is like let me see your car
keys and i'm like okay
certainly josh isn't gonna do anything
behind my back
so uh i go i have i had a one-on-one i
had a meeting with an employee
right before i had to head down for like
an hour and 30 minute drive uh so from
beaver creek ohio down to like
cincinnati which is about hour 30
minutes um i did do this i had to have
this quick meeting so i have this quick
meeting
uh
josh gives back my car keys i go out
into the parking lot to open up
my truck
and what josh and this employee have
done is they pranked me pranks are
always funny when they're done to
someone else not when they're done to
you though and filled my truck with
packing peanuts
[Laughter]
and i was already late for this meet i
was already like running
on like you know that didn't have a
whole lot of extra time for this meeting
i mean up to like his channel oh yeah it
was
yes yes
so i open
i open up the the truck pack i'm just
like trying to get as many of the
packing peanuts out so much litter
i'm driving down
i-75 with the windows down like throwing
packing peanuts out the window
it was
hindsight um
it was definitely today i was very yeah
i was very uh i was so i've i'd haven't
been that mad in a long time up to that
point i was so mad i i still don't
really understand the anger mainly
because i was already running late to
this meeting
and i ended up being late and got it was
like my first like legit meeting i had
as as my with my new position
so like i was just starting off on the
on the wrong foot
because i knew i'd be late eventually i
didn't plan on it being the very first
time actually to be somewhere
representing this new position that i
had so the timing was was definitely i
don't understand i don't understand the
anger either as much as like that's what
it was and i sure definitely overreacted
um but uh
but yeah how would i handle that today
holy moly dude i would just make whoever
did it clean it up and i wouldn't
freaking go anywhere so whoever did it
cleaned it up i don't know man i i think
i think that if you didn't have a
meeting to go to or whatever i think you
would have found it like so hilarious
probably i think you would have probably
just sat in it and like taken pictures
in it probably yeah probably yeah if
time wasn't of the essence right yeah
yeah you're right you're right anyway so
that's the story
uh so anyone listening to this if
someone just randomly asks for your car
keys do not do not give them
that person
i'll just i guarantee you they don't
have something they don't have something
uh benevolent planned for you i i'll
append it i i didn't necessarily ask for
your car keys i asked for your keys i
need to get into the stock room oh maybe
that's what it was yeah yeah yeah and so
i did actually go into the stock room
with them and got some where we were
hiding the packing penis
oh man you and yeah sean reynolds
other other other show the other other
other sean yeah oh wow he's a good guy
anyway
did you enjoy this video if so you can
listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists today your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel 100
percent advertisement free